en el vídeo anterior vimos cómo usa tres
puntos para definir un arco parabólico
más adelante hablaremos de cómo definir
el ancho el color el movimiento y la
variedad que se necesita para crear un
campo de pasto convincente primero
hablemos las matemáticas para crear un
programa por computadora para los
artistas un programa como este por
ejemplo en donde puedo jalar los puntos
y la parábola se ajusta entonces qué
tipo de matemáticas se necesitan para
hacer este programa primero hablemos
sobre cómo computar la ubicación de los
puntos que vamos a unir con líneas usan
una estructura de hilo ahora algunos de
estos puntos son un poco más fáciles de
construir que otros y los más fáciles
son estos de aquí dos puntos medios este
punto de aquí es el punto medio de este
segmento este de otro y así nos seguimos
entonces analicemos las matemáticas de
los puntos medios así que aquí tengo un
segmento de línea ave y el punto medio
de este segmento de línea será alguien
por la mitad
este punto amarillo y vamos a llamarle q
ahora la pregunta es si conozco las
coordenadas de a no sé supongamos que
son a subíndice equis y ya subíndice jr
y de forma similar supongamos que las
coordenadas de ver son b subíndice x y b
subíndice y entonces la pregunta es qué
coordenadas tiene como bien si lo
analizas un minuto te vas a dar cuenta
de que kun está a la mitad entre ay ver
en la dirección x y a la mitad entre a y
b en la dirección jeff y podemos
calcular un punto como ese
simplemente promediando la coordenada x
de cum será el promedio de las
coordenadas x de ahí ve así que tenemos
a x más bx esto entre 2 y la coordenada
jeff será agent más beijing entre 2
este es un cálculo muy sencillo
inclusive puede abreviar lo y que se vea
aún más simple al escribir como como a
más ven entre dos y esto significa que
tomamos el promedio de x y el promedio
de ayer
así que estas dos expresiones significan
lo mismo ahora bien nuestra escultura de
hilo requiere más que un solo par de
puntos medios pero podemos crear tantos
puntos como queramos al calcular puntos
medios de puntos medios por ejemplo aquí
solo tenemos un par de puntos medios
aquí y ahora voy a calcular el punto
medio de este subsegmento y otro punto
medio en este otro sub segmento y lo
mismo con estos dos segmentos y así
obtengo tres puntos en cada recta y
puedo crear tantos como quieras y
simplemente continuamos con el proceso
del punto medio del punto medio a
continuación podrás trabajar con estas
ideas